bootle cat podcast look man shout out to
LRG shout out to Def Jam we're in
Arizona for the Super Bowl and we got
everybody pulling up this guy had the
number one freestyle 2023 or 2022. what
year is it I'm [__] up 2022
with OCD Osman Benjamin let's get it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's the word
it's me Osmond Godfrey Benjamin you
heard your favorite black man shout out
to vibeland shout out to Bootleg cab
shout out to my wife hey I love you girl
you feel me
I'm trying not to [__] this up Kev
look my producer black disc jockey when
we play it's a full house we never seen
a DJ Tanner black Excellence with
numbers you can hang from the Raptors
it's a good year to retire rappers I got
mine will align God talking provided me
with a gold mine comparable to
glassberg's street fighting Supremacy
until Ro reversal seen in our history
and all my kin Masters look it's all
this cinnamon on the lips of man you
know spicy talk don't send for me I know
cinnamon and I'll send them in be honest
Adriana's [__] that [__] put them on
the Gilded until they end up on an
island like they Gilligan wins them in
the crown it's not a drill this ain't no
feelings [__] risen War enough to break
the scale y'all [__] dealing with a
monster ain't no Hardy Hall leader LOLs
and they're working for Kevin nathione
don't debate me dog see I speak to the
economy with Spirit you fly spirit and
economy you copy me as the different
type of plane we don't know the stakes
they ain't a grill they're going
Fellaini online scene through the feet
I'm the crocodile lady slipped to find a
new balance these 550s from Amy dog see
I'm the one player Monica now I'm a
Grady dog my [__] this is God's work I
speak in scripture these is God's words
were checking I just send the lead to
the a metaphor through the madhouse been
going crazy being dopes that are
speaking my heart do I be as honest as
possible about these obstacles a falsify
statements I withdraw the author and the
King Pen Mighty in an assorted and my
ballpoint always been my weapon of
choice so hold me accountable for a
counter my life until my account is full
Commerce for the reason they doubted you
I've been a rock boy Cornerstone and
Foundation the bass kid that's obsessed
with his modulation see I never been
complacent when them walls closed in
because the gutter basement is
confirmation of a renovation I'm
building [__] on my father the way I
handle business with recording it's
freaking mortar the audio so tangible I
deliver a field of people buy into like
twin speakers in the storefront guard my
messages got delivered no matter the
coordinates or these scissors cut yellow
tape full of caution gear I see the
crime scene and I know I did it no I'm
guilty of relaying the scripture while I
facilitate a division see I plead guilty
and do the massive convicting with no
conviction and let my penmanship be the
sentiment of my sentence and through
these bars let the onlookers know that
there's Beauty inside the blemishes look
the Lord amongst the Thieves for
collectioning the devil amongst the
plates and they Fellowship offering
collecting through embellishment
synagogue is still with synods wrapped
in guard like temperament Shepherd
promoting settling the Sheep is
crucified for these esoteric Endeavors
that they decided to meddle in you want
to know why black people they only have
nightmares because the last dreamer
called metal inside his melanin we visit
heaven when we asleep and wake up in
hell again and again the story of the
demonized gentlemen see everybody Stope
about being this woke [__] but I see
God most when eyes closed in his there I
feel God most when I'm close to the last
my bungee made a face yeah I chose
Discord instead I gave him a lie down to
the arm leg and a leg and kept a special
arm to aim at the half that's God body
what's up
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week